IN HIS STUDIO THERE.
A PRETTY AMAZING CONVERSATION.
HERE'S PART OF IT.
SO WE ARE SITTING WHERE YOU
MAJOR MOST RECENT ALBUM IN.
I HOPE YOU GET A FULL SHOT
BECAUSE I'VE NEVER SEEN ANYTHING
LIKE THIS.
WHEN DID YOU MAKE THIS ALBUM?
>> WE GOT THE STUDIO DOWN, WRITE
EVERYTHING DOWN FOR MY MICHIGAN
STUDIOS RIGHT BEFORE [BLEEP] HIT
THE FAN.
>> Tucker: TO BE 20.
>> COVID
YOU KNOW, YOU SPEND YEARS WITH
THAT FIRST ALBUM AND FROM THERE,
IT'S GETTING MORE RECORDS OUT
WHEN YOU HIT A LICK AND BE
SUCCESSFUL.
THIS RECORD HAVING A COUPLE OF
YEARS TO FIND TUNE EVERY LYRIC
AND EVERY NOTE AND LEAVING SOME
STUFF FOR ALL TO SEE WHAT WORKS,
WHAT DOESN'T, KEEPING THE GO
BACK TO THE DRAWING BOARD WAS A
LUXURY.
YOU SAY IT, EVERYBODY SAYS, THIS
IS MY BEST ALBUM!
OF COURSE.
SELL, SELL.
BUT IT REALLY IS...
IN MY HEART IT IS ONE OF MY BEST
EFFORTS IN A LONG TIME.
>> Tucker: YOU BEEN DOING THIS
30 YEARS BUT YOU STILL BRING
INTENSITY TO IT.
HOW OFTEN DO YOU COME HERE?
>> I'M A WORKAHOLIC.
I'M USUALLY THE LAST ONE OUT AT
6:00 AT NIGHT.
>> Tucker: IN THE STUDIO?
>> YEAH.
3:30 IN THE MORNING I'M WRITING
TO MY DOING, CHECKING EMAILS.
7:00 A.M., MY BUDDY COMES IN,
PLAY PICKLE BALL, DO SOME
CARDIO.
HE WILL START SHOWING UP AT
9:30, MY ENGINEER GETS HERE AT
9:30 AND WE RECORD ALL DAY.
GRANDPA GETS A LITTLE NAP IN THE
OTHER ROOM.
GROUNDHOG DAY, DO IT AGAIN.
THINGS ARE FEELING GOOD, CRACK
SOME BEERS, HAVE A BIG TIME
FRIDAY-SATURDAY, RELAXED SUNDAY,
GET BACK TO IT.
>> Tucker: THAT'S AMAZING.
YOU ARE A ROCK STAR WITH
ACCOUNTANT HOURS.
>> YEAH.
I PLAY ONE ON TV PRETTY WELL.
>> THERE IS A LOT DISCIPLINED
AROUND IT?
>> THIS DOESN'T HAPPEN WITHOUT
DISCIPLINE.
PEOPLE SEE THE WILD SIDE AND THE
PARTIES SIDE AND HOPEFULLY SOME
OF THE CHARITABLE THINGS AND
THINGS I'VE DONE THROUGH THE
YEARS.
THERE ARE BOTH SIDES.
BUT I WORK MY ASS OFF.
WHEN PEOPLE ASK ME ADVICE, I
SAY, I WORK HARDER THAN YOU
APPEAR THAT'S WHAT HAPPENED.
>> Tucker: WHAT WAS THE IDEA
BEHIND THIS ALBUM?
>> IT CAME TOGETHER AT THE END
MY CALLING IT "BAD REPUTATION.
PRETTY MUCH SUMS ME UP.
IT'S EVERYTHING.
I WANTED TO GO A LITTLE BIT BACK
TO MY ROOTS, HARD ROCK, HARD
WRAP MUST VEER STUFF, BUT I
WANTED TO THROW IN THE TUNES OF
SOUTHERN ROCK AND COUNTRY MUSIC
AND THE SOUL MUSIC, AND
ROCK 'N' ROLL.
ALL WHICH I LOVE SO MUCH AND
HAVE REALLY HONED MY CRAFT OVER
THE YEARS TO NOT JUST BE FLUENT
IN ONE, BUT THE TOUCH ON THEM
ALL.
>> Tucker: IS...
SO IF THERE WAS A MEASURED
BEHIND THE ALBUM, WHAT WOULD IT
BE?
>> TO MY FANS?
I LOVE YOU DEARLY.
TO MY CRITICS AND HATERS, GO
[BLEEP] YOURSELF.
>> Tucker: YOU'RE NOT HIDING
THAT MESSAGE.
>> EVERYTHING I DO...
TO SOLIDIFY MY FANS, I LOVE THE
TROLLS, THE HATERS, THE CRITICS
WHO HAVE BEEN TRYING TO KNOCK ME
DOWN TO 20-30 YEARS, I'M STILL
STANDING OPERATING AT THE
HIGHEST LEVELS.
SOMETIMES I DO THINGS
PURPOSEFULLY JUST TO BE A WISE
THE FANS WILL GET THE
TONGUE-IN-CHEEK AND THE PEOPLE
WILL HATE ME.
IT'LL JUST PISS THEM OFF MORE.
>> Tucker: WHY HAVEN'T YOU
BEEN CANCELED?
>> I AM UNCANCELLABLE.
>> Tucker: WHY IS THAT?
>> I DON'T GIVE UP [BLEEP].
AT THE END OF THE DAY I I'M
I HAVE NOONE I'M BEHOLDEN TO.
YOU CAN'T CANCEL ME.
I LOVE IT WHEN THEY TRY.
>> Tucker: WHY AREN'T THERE
MORE ARTIST LIKE THAT?
>> BECAUSE THEY ARE IN BED WITH
RECORD COMPANIES AND CORPORATE
DEALS AND STRUCTURES AT EVERY
LEVEL.
YOU KNOW...
IF SOMEONE FINDS A WAY TO GET ME
HERE AND THERE, I'LL FIND
ANOTHER WAY AROUND THEM.
>> YOU NEVER SEE ARTIST TALK
LIKE THAT.
THEY SEEM EASY TO INTIMIDATE.
AT ONE POINT DO YOU REALIZE THAT
YOU JUST AREN'T GOING TO BE
INTIMIDATED?
>> DAY ONE QUESTION MIKE I
CRAWLED OUT OF THE WOMB WITH
BOTH MIDDLE FINGERS IN THE AIR.
A LOT OF IT IS A LITTLE FUN IN
THERE, BE ROCK 'N' ROLL, THIS,
THAT, AND THE OTHER.
BECAUSE MY ART IS BIG AT THE END
OF THE DAY AND I HAVE LOVE AND
RESPECT WHO SHOWS THAT BACK TO
ME.
BUT GRANDPA AIN'T PLANO MESS
EITHER.
SPEAK WITH THE OTHER GUYS IN
YOUR INDUSTRY TELL YOU, I WISH I
COULD SAY WHAT YOU --
>> EVERY [BLEEP] DAY.
ESPECIALLY THE COUNTRY GUYS
BECAUSE THEY HAD TO BE
UNDERSTANDABLY CAREFUL.
THE AWARDS, RADIO, CORPORATE
INTEREST MEAN A LOT TO COUNTRY
MUSIC.
ROCK 'N' ROLL IS LIKE, YOU'RE
GETTING AWARD FOR THIS AIR
LIKE -- I COULDN'T CARE LESS
ABOUT THEIR AWARDS.
I NEVER PLAY THAT ANY OF THOSE
GAMES ANYWAY.
>> Tucker: YOU MUST'VE WATCHED
A LOT OF PEOPLE FLOWED OFF IN
THE ATMOSPHERE >> Tucker: I'M
COMING
>> I'M COME AND GO.
>> Tucker: WE'VE ALL SEEN UP
WELL BEHIND THE MUSIC."
HOW DO YOU GET ABOVE THAT.
>> I HAVE A SENSE OF DISCIPLINE.
WHETHER IT'S BACK IN THE DAY
WITH DRUGS AND ALCOHOL, YOU GO,
WHAT'S IMPORTANT?
EVENTUALLY, YOU CUT SOME THINGS
OUT, YOU FOCUS ON WHAT YOU LOVE.
FOCUS ON FRIENDS, FAMILY, MUSIC,
WHAT'S IMPORTANT IN LIFE.
YOU DON'T HAVE SO MUCH TIME.
MAKE THE MOST OF YOUR TIME.
>> Tucker: WHO ARE YOUR FANS?
DO YOU HAVE A PICTURE OF WHO
THEY ARE?
>> HARDWORKING FOLKS WHO LOVE TO
HAVE A GOOD TIME.
>> Tucker: DO YOU HEAR FROM
THEM?
>> HOW CAN YOU NOT HEAR FROM
PEOPLE THESE DAYS?
>> Tucker: YOU HAVE A PRETTY
GOOD SENSE OF WHAT THEY THINK?
>> THEY SEEM TO THINK THINGS I
DO.
NOT ALL OF THEM, NOT EVERYONE'S
VIEWS ONLINE.
FRIENDS WHO ARE STILL LEFT IN A
LITTLE FARTHER THAN THAT ON SOME
THINGS, I LOVE GETTING TOGETHER
WITH THEM AND CUTTING IT UP AND
TALKING A COUPLE OF THINGS AND
HEAR FROM BOTH SIDES.
I THINK THAT'S IMPORTANT.
>> Tucker: YOU ARE GOING ON
TOUR.
WHERE ARE YOU GOING?
>> A LOT OF MIDWEST AND SOUTH,
EAST COAST, SELECT DATES ON THE
WEST COAST.
AMERICA!
I DON'T SHOW A PASSPORT TOO
MUCH.
>> Tucker: YOU DON'T?
YOU'VE BEEN AROUND THE WORLD...
>> I SHOW NO INTEREST.
I SEE WHY SOME BANDS DO IT.
IF I WANTED TO BE THE BIGGEST
DEAL IN EVERY COUNTRY IN THE
WORLD, I COULD.
BUT I LIKE MY OWN BED.
I'M BIG IN KENTUCKY, MAN!
>> Tucker: THAT'S GOOD TO
KNOW.
SO YOU ARE NOT PLAYING VENUES
THAT REQUIRE VAX CARDS?
>> NO!
THAT'S WHAT THEY HAD RYAN LEFT
FROM THE LEFT, KID ROCK SAID...
GREAT, SO MY TOUR FOR ME.
THERE WOULD BE NO VAX CARDS BY
THE TIME WE TOURED.
THE ONLY PLACE WE DIDN'T THAT WE
DECIDED NOT TO PLAY WITH
BUFFALO, NEW YORK, BECAUSE
NEW YORK LOOK LIKE YOU PROBABLY
COULD HAVE SOMETHING WHERE YOU
HAVE TO WEAR A MASK OR SHOW UP
WITH A CAR